[Music]
Oh.
>> Oh,
>> I like that better.
>> All right. Sorry, we're going to we're a
couple minutes late.
Uh, welcome to the September 8th Finance
Committee meeting. I'm going to be your
host all evening. So
sit tight. We're going to move through
this quickly. Hopefully
we are going to kick it off with one new
resolution we have tonight 7825 coming
through water water pollution and with
Mr. Wing.
>> Yes. Thank you Mr. Chairman. Um, as many
of you probably know, on August 27th, a
portion of the West Main Street sewer um
between Sloum and Welsh collapsed and
create a sinkhole. And the water
pollution control department uh tried to
do a spot fix, but it continued to um
continue to break and collapse. So, they
had to end up replacing the whole line
from manhole to manhole. And uh this
resolution authorizes that work to be
done and waves competitive bidding
because it is an emergency. Um,
Superintendent Curtis WH has quite a bit
more information about this. I'd like to
ask ask him to say a few words.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Thank you, Councilman
Wing. Um, as Councilman Wing stated, a
sinkhole was discovered on West Main
Street and during the investigation of
handling it, the repair was decided to
just repair the area that of the
sanitary sewer that had collapsed. But
unfortunately during the repair work,
the 100-year-old pipe had fractures from
almost upstream manhole to downstream
manhole. And as the repair work was
going on, each joint that was next in
line collapsed in on itself during the
process. After this happened twice, um I
was called out to the site to
investigate, take a look at it, at which
point I decided with the age and the
fractures we were still going to
encounter that it would be best just to
replace this pipe itself. Um, so that
afternoon the contractor Rock River
worked up an estimate for me and got it
back to me and I requested that this
work be done right away considering the
hole was still open, that the sanitary
sewer itself was open, flowing still,
and just to decrease any type of public
hazard and hopefully decrease any
possible additional costs that would
come by keeping it open for a couple
more weeks. I wanted that work done just
as soon as possible.
Taylor,
>> they're going to replace the entire pipe
all the way down West Main.
>> It is from Sloum Avenue and West Main to
the um alley east of Sloum Avenue. It's
170 linear feet is what they replaced.
>> Okay. Because that is a bad has always
been bad. So they'll repave and all that
then.
>> They've paved over where the work was
done.
>> Okay.
>> Any other questions?
No.
>> Thank you.
>> Absolutely. Thank you,
>> Mr. Wing.
>> Yes. So, uh, due to the nature of this
piece, I will be requesting, uh, one
reading and suspension during the
regular meeting and Councilman Als will
be my second.
>> All right. Thank you. Do we have any
other resolutions that are not on my
agenda we need to go over? No. Great.
Ordinances. New ordinances starting with
temporary ordinance 4625
coming through economic development.
Mrs. soup.
>> Yes, thank you. This is just to accept
the 163 plus acres um out of Greenfield
Township on Wilson Road.
And Stephanie, do you have anything to
add?
>> Um this is uh going to expand the
Rockmill Industrial Park at another 163
acres. Uh one of the parcels is in
contract currently with a foreign
manufacturer. Um and uh um yep, this is
going to this is going to update the
zoning map. It'll be advanced
manufacturing just like the neighboring
uh parcels.
>> Any questions from anyone?
>> Does this new manufacturer use a lot of
water?
>> Um this one currently the manufacturing
portion the manufacturing functions do
not utilize a lot of water. Okay. Yeah,
>> thanks.
>> Sure. We do have some actually I'll say
most of manufacturing does not use that
much water anymore. Um but we're very
cognizant of it um of how much we have
over there.
>> Okay. Thank you. Miss who?
>> Um Councilman
Councilwoman Crates is going to be my
second.
>> Three.
>> Three readings. Yeah.
>> All right.
uh temporary ordinance 47 also coming
through economic development.
>> Yeah, it's a companion piece. So, this
one is the zoning portion of the
annexation. It has to go to planning
commission first, but to get three
readings, we're starting now. So, the
minutes from the planning commission
will be added later.
>> Okay.
>> And Councilman Wing is going to be my
second. Any questions on those two
pieces? Anybody? Nobody.
>> Okay. Temporary ordinance 4825. That's
coming through public works. Miss Tiner.
>> Yes. We kind of inherited we were given
a um cemetery that's up above where the
Clarence Miller used building used to be
the infirmary there on 37. And uh we're
getting granted an easement so that we
can continue mowing it because we've
been mowing it for well probably since
2014 or 2015. And um so this is just so
that we can get the easement so that we
can continue mowing in that area.
>> Okay.
Anything to add anyone?
>> Tim, is there anything else?
>> All right. We got time.
Good evening. Um, basically what this
does, when we inherited that cemetery,
it's a it's a city-owned piece of
property. It's happen to be landlocked.
Can't get to it unless we cross some
private property. Back when we got it,
the county owned the building, so we
really didn't have any issues getting
from the parking lot to the cemetery
because we're going across county
property. But they sold it to a private
individual who's been very accommodating
to us. But moving forward uh should he
sell the property to somebody else, we
felt with the need for a permanent
easement. So they could not restrict our
access to that cemeteries for as long as
we have to maintain it. So part of that
will allow us to do our work, but we'll
also maintain the property we're
crossing in the parking lot, portion of
the parking lot we're using to stage our
equipment. And when we're there, we'll
maintain that in perpetuity.
>> Sounds good. Anyone have any questions?
Seeing none, I have two readings.
>> Mrs. Crates, as your second,
>> I don't see any other ordinances. We
just
sped through those quickly. So,
department updates. Do we have anyone
here wanting to give a department
update,
Miss Woody?
So, I have two updates for you. The
first one I passed out to each member of
council um the water rates. So, this is
kind of a companion to temporary
ordinance 4125.
According to our ordinances, city
council sets the rates for our
wastewater. However, it leaves it up to
the service safety director's office to
set the water rates. So, as part of the
rate study that you all received and
reviewed a couple weeks ago, I wanted to
kind of put it in a snapshot for you
what the new proposed water rates will
be based on that new rate study. So, the
first column is it describes whether
it's residential outside the corporation
limit the com and then the different
commercial rates.
The existing rates are what we are
currently billing in 2025.
The next column that says 2022 study
rates, this is what the this is what the
rates would be in 2026 based off of our
prior rate study that was completed in
2022. So, if we did not take into
consideration the new recommendation for
rates, that is what the rates would be
for our residents, outside corporation,
and commercial.
Based on the new rate study that was
just completed that you received a
couple weeks ago, the new proposed rates
are in that following column for 2026.
So, as you can see, based on the new
rate study, residents will actually see
a a they will not receive any increase
at all from 2025. It will actually be a
decrease than as what was proposed in
the original 2022 study. Same for
outside the corporation, the commercial
1 to 100 cubic feet, the commercial 101
to 250 cubic cubic feet. Um, so you can
just kind of see that snapshot rates as
based on the new rate study. And so I
wanted to provide that to all of council
so that you would be fully aware. The
intention would be to implement this new
rate structure as of January 1st of
2026.
Um at the same time to coincide if
council does approve the wastewater
rates based on the current study
the flat rate. Oh uh as mayor nicely
pointed out we are again just like the
wastewater ordinance that was before you
we are recommending that we go to that
flat rate for all users and that would
eventually go into effect then as you
see by 2029 everybody would have a flat
rate for water use. And again, same idea
as your wastewater rates is that a
gallon of water is a gallon of water.
So, I'm open to any questions that you
have based on this rate study. Um, but
again, it was for your information so
that you can see that and we can all be
on the same page for that.
Having no questions for that, my next
piece is much more fun. In 2024, um the
city applied for a grant uh called the
Better Cities for Pets, and it was a
$20,000 grant that the city was awarded
that we partnered with the Fairfield
Area Humane Society on. and it is a way
to help promote um pet friendly
businesses in the city of Lancaster to
highlight and showcase some of our
businesses that are pet friendly and
also do some PR education and
programming um to help individuals
throughout the community adopt pets. So
what we are currently working on is we
have created an application that is
currently live on our website. However,
it's the whole program hasn't been
rolled out yet. But we are going to have
little signs for businesses to apply
online whether they are pet friendly or
not. And if they are pet pet friendly,
they can say that pets are welcome. They
can say pets are welcome on our patio or
they can say we love pets but they
aren't allowed inside. And that will be
an indication to pet owners on what type
of business it is throughout the city.
And then in addition, again, we're going
to do some education around pets and
eventually then do some programming to
try and do like uh take a pet out for
the day or foster for a day, I guess,
for a lack of better words, if you will.
I'll defer to Mr. Skoonover, President
Skooover of the evening.
>> Um,
yes, thank you. So, this is kind of a
long time coming project uh for for us.
Um it so just just a little bit of
background. So the better cities for
pets program you can you can be awarded
that status based on certain things in
your community. The and then they have a
grant program to go along with it. So we
were we were one of five nationwide that
got a grant last year for that. So, um,
looking at where we lacked in terms of
pet friendliness in town, whether it's
housing or whatever, business was
businesses was the biggest thing. So,
trying to get, you know, we have a ton
of tourism that that we see um people
when they're traveling with their pets
more often than not these days. Hey,
where can I go with the pet? So, this is
kind of step one. And then Miss Woody
was referring to what I like to call our
doggy day out program. So, you know, I'm
in the business of adopting animals. So,
if you're not able to adopt an animal,
but you want to come take one out for
the day, let them get out of the
shelter, this program kind of partners
with that. So, folks know where they can
go with their pet. they can know, you
know, who's who's pet friendly or even,
you know, again, maybe maybe it's a
restaurant, you can't bring your dog in,
but they are still pet friendly and they
have something for you. So, uh you'll
see it on I think on the website under
community, it has a link uh for that.
So, then you'll start seeing businesses
participate and then we'll start kind of
doing that um outside of and hopefully a
countywide program. So, it's kind of
cool to to see that come to fruition.
So, I like the signs, too.
>> Yep. And in case you're wondering, City
Hall is pet friendly. Pets are welcome
in city hall. In fact, several of the
offices, mine, I know the auditor's
office, utilities, we keep uh dog
treats, dog biscuits in our office so
that when Councilman Tiner comes in, we
uh
>> And I am so sorry he pooped in your
hallway.
Well, you took up his grassy area
because of the scaffolding and that's
where he always goes and he got in. I
couldn't get him out in time and I
cleaned it up. It was okay. But it was
right between service safety director's
office and
>> but it wasn't personal.
>> Yeah,
>> he was mad because his grassy area was
gone.
>> But we do keep treats in the building so
that when pets do come in, we can give
them a treat. So there
>> and that's all I have. Thank you.
>> Good manners.
>> Hey, thank you for bringing it up. Um,
any other department updates? Stephanie?
>> There's just not enough on the agenda,
so I figured I'd just make some things
up to come talk to you. But um, I sent
you all an email Friday talking about
tiffs for the Sheridan Road project and
um, Steve and I had a good back and
forth and um, just wanted to make sure
you all know I'm available to ask
questions. I can answer questions um
tonight um or we you can give me a ring
and we'll get together and we can chat.
So, just wanted to make sure you all
know I'm I'm available for questions.
So,
>> any questions while she's standing
there? No. Thank you.
>> Okay.
>> Anyone else?
Going once,
going twice. That's not Bob Barker. I'm
sticking with Bob Barker tonight. Please
pay new to your pets. So, That's his
tagline. It's not going once. All right,
we're done with department updates. Uh,
council meeting prep. That's me. I don't
have any. We'll get into it as we go.
There's a couple pieces on there. Not
pieces.
Um, where's my agenda
with in new business? Um,
can I do it now or do we have to wait?
liquor license stuff. I I was just
informed like Roosters as an example. We
don't even know what that notification
exactly was for. Is that correct, Mitch?
>> Well, we already had a liquor license
option for that.
>> We received the police about Sorry, I'm
sorry. I'm new here. I didn't know they
turned that on.
>> I know you're like, "Great. He called on
me. He said he wouldn't."
>> That's okay.
>> You're welcome.
>> So, we we received one for Roosters um
that looks a little bit different than
what Anitro showed me uh this evening.
Um, we did for for what it's worth. We
talked to the chief of police about
about Roosters. I mean, we all we're all
familiar. I don't think we had any
issues in particular with that one. And
then I think there's a transfer uh as
well that you have in front of you
tonight. Um, I forget exactly
>> and that's the one that I wanted to
address. So, that transfer we didn't So,
we don't have any new information or new
or information on the new owner.
>> That's correct. We don't have
information on the new owner. Um,
nothing to report.
>> Okay. So, that one we're just going to
leave. We're not, you know, we usually
just vote to
>> Okay.
>> We're just going to not address the
Brucey's drive-thru one. Is that
>> It's not due until
>> Yeah, since it's not due until after the
next meeting, we're just not going to
address that one. So, I want you guys to
think, well, why did we skip over that?
So, that's why we're skipping over it
because we have no good information.
Other than that, I don't have anything
any other
items for finance that we want to
discuss.
Everybody's super quiet tonight. I like
it. All right,
we are going to Well, I need a motion to
adjurnn.
>> So move.
>> Motion a second. We are adjourned at
6:20 regular meeting. We cannot start
before 6:30, so we'll start promptly at
6:30. Thank you.
The Frankie Smith Funeral Home and
Crematory in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community. Feel free to give us a
call at 740-653652.
Stop in and see us at either of our two
locations, 405 North Columbus Street in
Lancaster and 207 South Main Street in
Baltimore. Respect for tradition, regard
for change.
>> Hi, this is Chuck Sims with the
Lancaster DARE program. DARE provides
students with skills to resist the
pressures of drugs, gangs, and violence,
and emphasizes self-esteem, good
decision-making, and communication
skills. This month, we're honored once
again to be chosen by Buckeye family's
Buckeye Cares program. For sponsoring
our events, to donating DARE vehicles,
or supporting us financially, we say
thank you, Buckeye, for all of your
support.
[Music]
Take your places everyone.
All right. Welcome. Um,
I'm not going to lie, I don't have a
prayer
set up. Uh, President Porter took that
with him on vacation. Um, but I'm going
to throw a shameless plug uh, as your
host this evening and the Bob Barker
theme, spaying new to your pets.
Please, if you run across anyone that
needs to spay a new to their pets, tell
them you know a guy. We offer lowcost
services.
Let's spay and neuter pets because no
one likes extra kittens, extra puppies.
That's my shameless plug for the Humane
Society. With that being said,
>> welcome.
>> Amen. Thank you.
>> Call the meeting to order. Uh let's do
the pledge of allegiance.
>> To the flag of the United States of
America and to the republic for which it
stands, one nation under God,
indivisible, with liberty and justice
for all.
Right. Thank you. Let's uh go ahead and
call the role.
>> Mr. AS here.
>> Mrs. Berler
>> here.
>> Mr. Bischoff here.
>> Mrs. Kra here.
>> Mrs. Hoop
>> here.
>> Mr. Luenberg
>> Mr. Skunover
>> here.
>> Mr. Sully
>> Miss Diner here. And Mr. Wing
>> here.
>> The record reflect that all 10 members
of council are present.
Reading and disposal of the journal.
>> I have regular meeting minutes dated
August 25th, 2025.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to accept the reading and disposing of
the journal.
>> Second.
>> Have a motion and second to accept the
reading disposing of the journal. All in
favor, please signify by saying I.
>> I.
>> All oppose. Same sign. Motion carries.
reports of city officials.
>> I have 10 of them. I have email dated
August 28th, 2025 of regular public
works regular meeting date change
submitted by Miss Tiner. Email dated
September 3rd, 2025 regarding strategic
relocation of fire stations submitted by
fire chief Slate Schultz. Email dated
August 26, 2025 regarding Elmwood Park
meeting time submitted by parks and rec
um recreation superintendent Steve
Gayfield. Email dated August 25th, 2025
regarding zoning changes for short-term
rentals um submitted by Mrs. Hoop.
Series of emails dated August 28th
regarding West Main Street sinkhole
submitted by environmental engineer
Denise Cruz. Email dated August 29th,
2025 regarding September 11th planning
commission meeting submitted by city
planner Chasyn Carter. Series of emails
dated August 26th regarding explanations
of temporary
resolution 73-25
and 74-25 submitted by environmental
engineer Denise Cruz.
Emails dated September 8th, 2025
regarding plant water, I'm sorry,
northwater plant costs submitted by
environmental engineer um Denise Cruz.
Email dated September 4th, 2025
regarding special council meeting
submitted by Mayor John McDaniel. And
finally, email dated September 7th,
2025, sunshine law training submitted by
Mr. Bisjack.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to accept reports of city officials.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to accept
and follow reports of city officials.
All in favor, please signify by saying
I.
>> I.
>> All oppose. Same sign. Motion carries.
Do we have any communications?
>> I have three. I have um mail received
September 2nd, 2025 regarding Brew Yak
LLC liquor license submitted by Ohio
Department of Commerce, Division of
Liquor Control.
Mail received second or September 2nd,
2025 regarding Rooers Lancaster, Inc.
Incorporated. Liquor license submitted
by Ohio Department of Commerce, Division
of Liquor Control. Email data September
3rd, 2025, regarding manufacturing
projects submitted by Zachary Gerald,
um, staff reporter, the Columbus
Business First.
>> Mr. President, like to make a motion to
accept communications.
>> Second motion, a second to accept and
file the communications. All in favor
signify by saying I.
>> I.
>> All oppose, same sign. Motion carries.
We have any special presentations this
evening?
>> I do not.
>> Do we have any petitions or memorials
this evening?
>> There are no petitions or memorials this
evening.
>> Now's the time we set aside for
for voters and taxpayers to address
council. Do we have anyone wanting to do
that this evening?
No. If not, no. Thank you all for being
here.
Uh reports of standing committees.
>> I have seven of them. I have code
enforcement zoning special meeting
agenda dated August 28th, 2025 submitted
by Mr. Sulli. I have law committee
meeting minutes dated September 1st,
2025 submitted by Mrs. Crates. I have
water water pollution committee meeting
minutes dated September 2nd, 2025
submitted by Mr. Wing. Um I have finance
committee meeting agenda dated September
3rd, 2025 submitted by Mr. over.
I have service committee meeting minutes
dated September 5th, 2025 submitted by
Mr. Als and public works committee
meeting minutes dated September 8th,
2025 submitted by Mrs. Ter or Miss Ter.
>> Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to accept uh reports of standing
committees. Second
>> a motion is second to accept the reading
or I'm sorry accept the reports of
standing committees.
Yeah,
I said that correctly, right? I just
totally lost my spot. I'm sorry.
>> Uh all in favor, please signify by
saying I.
>> I.
>> All oppose, same sign. Motion carries.
Okay, we have no public hearings
tonight. Correct.
>> Correct.
>> All right. We're moving into the fun
stuff reading a resolution starting with
the third reading of temporary
resolution 6725.
a resolution authorizing the city
administration to act on behalf of the
city of Lancaster and enter into any and
all agreements or settlements necessary
to participate in the new national
opioid settlements with Al Vogan
Incorporated, Amne Pharmaceutical
Incorporated, Appotex Incorporated,
Hikima Pharmaceuticals USA Inc. and
Inivior
Inc., Myion Pharmaceuticals Inc., Sun
Pharmaceuticals Industrious Incitus
Pharmaceuticals USA Inc. and to declare
an emergency. This is through law
committee. Mrs. Crates and Mr. Big
Bjack.
>> Mrs. Crates.
>> Yes. Thank you, Mr. President. I would
like to make a motion that council pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record resolution temporarily numbered
67-25.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second. Any
discussion? Miss Crates. Uh just
briefly, just a reminder, these are
there are new settlements related to the
national opioid crisis. Um and this
legislation authorizes the city to join
those.
>> Any questions from anyone?
>> Else call a roll.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mrs. Bitler,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack, yes.
>> Mrs. Kit, yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Lenberg,
>> Mr. Skoonver,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Sully,
>> Miss Tinder, yes. And Mr. Wing,
>> yes.
Motion carries 10 to zero. Temporary
resolution 7025,
>> a resolution authorizing the service
safety director to enter an engineering
agreement for updating the division of
water asset management plan as required
by the Ohio Environmental Protection
Agency and Ohio Water Development
Authority. It's through water water
pollution control committee. Mr. Wing
and Miss Te.
>> Mr. Wing. Yes. Thank you, Mr. President.
I'd like to make a motion that council
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
number 7025.
>> Second.
>> Uh we have a motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 7025. Discussion.
>> Yes, we actually had a very thorough
discussion about this in committee. So,
I would like to make a few comments. Um
as all of you know, this uh piece
authorizes up to $150,000
for the water department to contract
with Arcadus for an asset management
plan. Um, as you also know, we have
excellent, excellent, um, operators in
the water department, but they're not
engineers. So, this brings in an
engineering perspective into the plan.
Um, a different firm would not know our
system nearly as well. It take them much
longer, and it'd be much more
inefficient. And, um, another positive
aspect I wanted to stress was having an
effective management plan would take our
water department, put it and put it more
into, um, a proactive state and rather
rather than a reactive state that we're
kind of in right now. So, uh, think this
is a great idea and I urge passage.
>> Thank you. Any questions, comments?
No. Seeing none, I'll ask the clerk to
call or call the role, please.
>> Mr. Eels,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Spiller,
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Crates,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Lenberg,
>> Mr. Screener,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Sully,
>> Miss Teener,
>> no.
>> Mrs. Dwing,
>> yes.
Motion passes 9 to one. Temporary
resolution
7125,
>> a resolution to authorize the service
safety director to advertise for a
request for qualifications and issue a
request for proposals for a design
professional for design a con
construction administration of the Ed
Road fire station project and to declare
an emergency. This is through safety
committee. Mr. Bisjack and Mr. Sully.
>> Mr. Bjac. Thank you, Mr. President. And
I move that council pass and engross
upon the Britain record. Temporary
resolution 71-25.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second to pass
temporary resolution 7125. Discussion.
>> Uh thank you, Mr. President. Uh this
legislation um was very simple. Once
again, allows the administration to go
out for request for qualifications to
see who's uh qualified to design a new
firehouse here out on Eden Road. Uh as
well as allowing the administration to
issue an RFP for that design.
That is all and there's no appropriation
attached to it. So that's all. Thank
you, Mr. President. Anything else? Any
questions?
Seeing none, we'll call the RO.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mrs. Bitler,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bischack,
>> Mrs. Kra, yes.
>> Mrs. H.
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Luxtober?
>> Mr. Scoover?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Sully?
>> Miss Tiner?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Wing?
>> Temporary resolution 7125 passes 10 to
zero. Let's
call for third reading. We're moving on
to second readings of resolutions
beginning with temporary resolution
7325.
>> A resolution to amend permanent
resolution 95-22 authorizing the service
safety director to enter into a contract
for construction of the northwater
treatment plant replacing project. This
is through water water pollution control
committee Mr. Wing and Mr. Als.
>> Mr. Wing. Yes. This is the second of
three readings.
Second of three readings on temporary
resolution 7325.
Temporary resolution 7425,
>> a resolution to authorize the mayor to
prepare and submit an application to
participate in the Ohio Environmental
Protection Agency Water Pollution
Control Loan Fund Program for the
planning, design, andor construction of
the Frederick Street sewer separation
project to execute contracts and
agreements as required and to designate
a dedicated repayment source for the
loan. Mr. Throughwater Water Pollution
Control Committee, Mr. Wing and Miss
Tiner.
>> Mr. Wing,
>> this is the second of three readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
resolution 7425.
Temporary resolution 7525.
>> A resolution to increase receipts
appropriate from the unencumbered
balance and to amend the certificate of
other sources and appropriations with
the county auditor and the special
improvement district fund 2020.
This is through finance committee. Mr.
Skunover or Miss Biller?
>> Mr. Skoonover be second of three
readings, please.
Second of three readings on temporary
resolution 7525.
>> Now we're moving on to 7625.
>> A resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an
agreement for engineering services for
the Lauren Street pump station
replacement project. This is through
water water pollution control committee.
Mr. Wing and Mr. Als.
>> Mr. Wing. Yes. This is the second of
three readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
resolution 7625
7725.
>> A resolution to authorize the mayor to
prepare and submit an application to
participate in the Ohio Public Works
Commission State Capital Improvement
Program and to execute contracts as
required. This is through water water
pollution control committee. Mr. Wing
and Miss Tiner.
>> Mr. Wing.
>> Yes. This is the second of three
readings. Second of three readings on
temporary resolution 7725.
Moving on to first readings of
resolutions. We have temporary
resolution 7825.
>> A resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into a contract
for construction of the West Main Street
sewer replacement project and to declare
an emergency. Mr. through water water
pollution control committee, Mr. Wing
and Mr. Als.
>> Mr. Wing.
>> Yes. Thank you, Mr. President. I'd like
to make a motion that council suspend
its rules and wave the second and third
reading of temporary resolution um I
think is that 7825
>> 7825
second
>> thank you we have a first and second on
suspending and waving the second third
readings of temporary resolution 7825
Mr. ing discussion.
>> Yes, that we just discussed this in
finance. This is for the emergency sewer
repair.
>> Great. Any other questions?
>> Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als, yes.
>> Mrs. Bitler,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bishack, yes.
>> Mrs. Kra, yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Lenberg,
>> Mr. Skunberg,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Sully,
>> Miss Tiner,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Wing,
>> Motion to suspend passes 10 to zero. Mr.
Wing.
>> Yes. Thank you, Mr. President. I'd like
to make a motion that council pass and
grist and enter upon the written record
temporary resolution 7825.
>> Second.
>> Wasn't that me?
>> We have a motion and a couple of seconds
to pass temporary resolution 7825. Any
other discussion?
>> Seeing none, please call the role.
>> Mr. S.
>> Yes.
>> Mrs. Ber,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mrs. Crates, yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Lockenberg,
>> Mr. Skinner,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Sully,
>> yes. Miss Tiner.
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Wayne.
>> Motion to pass carries 10 to zero.
We have any other ordinances to come
before council this evening?
Answer is no. Moving on to ordinances
beginning with third readings. Uh first
temporary ordinance 3725.
an ordinance to establish new permanent
right-of-way along a new center line in
connection with the Arbor Valley Drive
rehabilitation project to VA vacate the
existing Arbor Valley Drive rightway
once the new Arbor Valley Drive rightway
is dedicated and to acquire a new
easement for the water main in the
connection with the new Lancaster High
School. This is through public works
committee. Miss Tener, Mr. Als,
>> Miss Tener.
>> Mr. Mr. President, I'd like to make a
motion that council spent um sorry, I
would like to make a motion that council
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance 3725.
>> Second.
>> Uh we have a motion in a second to pass
temporary ordinance 3725. Discussion.
>> Yeah, this is just helping to realign
the easement so that the project and
that can move forward and they can get
everything finished.
>> Any other discussion? Seeing none,
please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes. Mrs. Berler,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Bisjack,
>> Mrs. Kra,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> yes. Mr. Lockenberg,
>> yes.
>> Mr. Scooter,
>> Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Miss Ter, yes.
>> And Mr. Wink,
>> yes.
>> Temporary ordinance 3725, passes 10 to
zero. Temporary ordinance 3825,
>> an ordinance amending part five, general
offenses code of the Langster codified
ordinances in adopting chapter 568,
camping prohibited. This is through law
committee. Mr. Bishack and Miss Ber.
>> Mr. Bishack.
>> Thank you, Mr. President. Uh, I move
that council uh pass and gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 38-25.
>> Second.
>> We have a first motion and a second to
pass temporary ordinance 3825.
Discussion.
>> Uh, thank you, Mr. President. Uh, the
city's been getting uh multiple
complaints about folks uh either, you
know, improperly or legally camping on
public and private property. uh this
ordinance is working to uh address that
concern that residents have given the
city and also give law enforcement code
enforcement a little bit more teeth in
addressing that. That's all. Thank you,
Mr. President.
>> Thank you. Any questions, comments?
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Um I did want to give a little bit of
background because I was contacted by a
number of citizens regarding this
legislation and I wanted to address a
couple of their concerns publicly. Um,
one is about the relationship of this
legislation with current administration
and events happening at the federal
level in Washington DC. I can assure you
they are unrelated. We started looking
at this u matter in quarter 1. Um, it
actually came up for the February
meeting which was continued to March and
that's the first time that we discussed
it which was before those events in DC.
Also just to um address the concern
about the limited facilities that we
have. We do have multiple facilities run
by private and public entities within
the city and the county offering health
and addiction services, beds and shelter
and includes different phases of the
process with additional facilities that
are under construction and also in
planning.
Additionally, I wanted to add that I
have um I have concerns with the
proposed legislation as as it's
currently written. It involves the
blanket inclusion of private property.
And while initially comfortable coming
out of committee, after further
researching the issue and digging into
it, I believe there are opportunities to
refine the language further so that it
isn't a blanket um inclusion of private
property. As an example, if I wanted my
grandkids to come over and sleep in the
backyard in a tent for a couple days, if
my neighbor had a problem with it, I
could be cited and fined under this
legislation. And I think that's
concerning.
Thank you.
>> Thank you. Any other questions? Mer.
>> Uh, thank you. Um, Mr. Skunover. Uh, I
did act a second on this. I have some of
the same concerns that Mrs. Kates has um
voiced and I will be voting no on this
as well.
>> Thank you.
Anyone else questions? Want to address
any of those concerns?
Well, I had similar concerns, but the
purpose stated, does that not clarify
that it's not for your backyard?
>> Mitch, do you have an answer for that? I
>> I got the thing this time. So, that's
correct. So, the purpose of the statute
is not to is is essentially not to
penalize what you just brought up,
Councilwoman Kits. Um, I I wrote this
piece of legisl I wrote this ordinance
and I had that in the back of my mind
the entire time. That's just not how our
enforcement wing at LPD or code
enforcement really works. Um I think the
mayor will attest to the fact that if if
I say we as a city if we go out there
you know to a situation where you know
whatever camping you can imagine it's
there's there's going to be multiple
opportunities for somebody to you know
essentially disperse and leave. Um, this
isn't, you know, this isn't a situation
where where, you know, we're trying to
legislate out, you know, kids camping in
tents. You know, there there's there's
no one out there who doesn't think that
somebody should be able to get their Boy
Scout or their Girl Scout badge, you
know, by by camping in the backyard. But
we do have some significant issues
across town with with, you know, people
camping in in trailers and campers and
RVs and tents and things like that. And
and by and large, we're unable to
address that issue. And so, while I
appreciate that there isn't a specific
carve out for what you're bringing up,
carving that out would actually defeat
the purpose of the statute because if I
carve out a private property camping
exception, well, then
you'd be able to camp on the private
property anyways. It would just defeat
the whole purpose. So, um, you know, I
take further questions. I hope that
addresses your concern.
So, it'd be kind of up to the discretion
of the officer or the code enforcement.
If somebody is camping for Girl Scouts,
Boy Scouts, they could say, "Hey,
they're just going to be here for a day
or two and then it's okay."
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay.
>> Anybody else? Before I circle back
around, Miss Crates,
>> go ahead.
>> Um, I understand that and I I appreciate
the fact that that's not the intent.
However, that doesn't mean that we don't
have a young, zealous police officer and
a very angry neighbor in a situation
that culminates into that perfect storm
where that situation does come to
fruition and a homeowner is, you know,
cited or something like that. It's not
preventing it is my point. I also know
that there are other mun at least one
other municipality which appears to have
legislation that would help take care of
the issues that we have as far as
private property, rightways, sidewalks,
entrances. um but doesn't have that
overarching private property blanket and
that's that's really my concern. Thank
you.
>> All right. Anybody else?
>> Seeing none, I'll ask we
are up for voting. We have a motion and
a second. So, please call the role.
>> Mr. Als,
>> yes.
>> Mrs. Butler,
>> no.
>> Mr. Bishack?
>> Yes.
>> Mrs. K?
>> No.
>> Mrs. Hoop?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Lockenberg?
>> Mr. Skunover?
>> Yes.
>> Mr. Sully,
>> yes.
>> Miss Tinder,
>> no.
>> Mr. Wing,
>> yes.
>> Motion carries. Temporary ordinance
passes 7 to three.
On to second readings of ordinances
beginning with temporary ordinance 4125.
>> An ordinance to amend title three.
Is that right?
>> Yeah. Title 3, Chapter 915 and 916 by
repealing and replacing existing
sections 915.04A,
915.05A
and 916.08
C of the codified ordinances of the city
of Lancaster, Ohio, and to declare an
emergency. This is through water water
pollution committee, Mr. Wing and Mr.
Als.
>> Mr. Wing.
>> Yes. Uh
I lost my train of thought here.
Second three.
>> Second of three. Sorry. Second three
readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 4125.
Temporary ordinance 4425.
>> An ordinance to amend Lancaster codified
ordinances. Ordinance Part 7, business
regulation code, chapter 709, the
cultivation, processing or dispensing of
medic medical marijuana or adult use of
cannabis by repealing and replacing
section 709.05
review and reapproval of adult use
cannabis moratorum. This is through law
committee. Mrs. Crates and Mrs. Beller.
>> Mrs. Crates.
>> Yes. Second of three readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 4425.
Temporary Ordinance 4525,
>> an ordinance to repeal and replace
existing permanent ordinance 21-2 24
section a setting public improvement
inspection fees pursuant to Lancaster
codified 1107.02A
and to declare an emergency through law
committee, Mrs. Kates and Mr. Bisjack.
>> Mrs. Crates.
>> Yes. Thank you. Second of three
readings.
>> Second of three readings on temporary
ordinance 4525.
Moving on to first readings, beginning
with temporary ordinance 4625,
>> an ordinance to accept the annexation of
163.434
plus or minus acres in Greenfield
Township and to declare an emergency is
through economic development um
committee. Mrs. Hoop and Mrs. Kates.
>> Mrs. Hoop.
>> This is first of three readings.
>> First of three readings on temporary
ordinance 4625.
Temporary Ordinance 4725,
>> an ordinance to amend the zoning map um
subject to passage of an annexation of
163.434
plus or minus acres in the Greenfield
Township and to declare an emergency
through economic development committee.
Mrs. Hoop and Mr. Wing,
>> Mrs. Hoop,
>> this is first of three readings. First
of three readings on temporary ordinance
4725.
Temporary ordinance 4825.
>> An ordinance to authorize the mayor to
accept an easement for access to the
closed county in infirmary cemetery on
parcel number 05331811
[Music]
and to declare an emergency. This is
food public works committee. Ms. Tiner
and Mrs. Kits.
>> Mrs. Tener.
>> First of two readings. First two
readings on temporary ordinance 4825.
Any other ordinances to become come
before council? One that I know of.
Moving on to tabled legislation. Do we
have any
movement on 3125? No. Okay.
>> We're going to have a hearing. There'll
be a hearing on that. So
>> 3925. Do we have any?
>> No. No, Mr. President, that's going to
be discussed at the special meeting.
>> Okay.
>> Moving on to unfinished business. Do we
have any unfinished business we want to
discuss?
>> Yes, sir.
>> No.
All right. New business. Yeah. Announce
the public hearing, please.
Or am I announcing that?
>> Oh, I put it up on your um special
council meeting. Okay, cool. It's a new
business, too. So,
>> you're good.
>> We'll talk about that later. We
discussed, if you're looking at your
agenda, we already discussed the liquor
license stuff. So, we can take some
action on the Rooers one. If I can get a
motion.
>> I move to approve the Rooers Lancasters,
Inc. liquor license.
>> Second.
>> Motion in a second. We just need a roll
call vote. Everyone in favor say I.
Hi. Hi. Hi,
>> Mr. President. Point of parliamentary.
If it's a roll call, don't you have to
call every roll call? Is a roll call or
v voice?
>> It's just
voice.
>> Call a roll then.
>> Yeah. Whatever.
>> No, I don't.
>> Okay.
>> We're all fine with Yes.
>> Is it legal,
>> Mr. Harden?
>> I think it is.
>> We got it. Good. We're good.
>> Question.
>> Under new business. Go ahead. Uh the
public hearing what time and where?
>> She moved it down into the meeting. So
she's going to read that.
>> Oh, got it.
>> Later.
>> So it's it's up there.
>> Oh, no. I apologize. There is a public
hearing next meeting. Um that'll be um
6:30 and here it is right here.
>> Thank you. Okay. I apologize. I was
incorrect. Um public hearing September
22nd, 2025. zoning map amendment due to
the annexation of the 163.4434
plus or minus acres from the Greenville
Township in the city of Lancaster.
>> Okay,
>> that's the public hearing.
>> That's next week.
>> I apologize, not the special meeting.
>> Um,
anything else for new business? I do I
know that you're going to read the
special meeting, but um I had a couple
different people reach out beforehand.
So, we have this special meeting that
was called scheduled for next Monday.
There are a couple of you that I've
heard that cannot attend.
So, how do we want to handle that?
Do we want to
revisit a new date? Do you want a couple
dates thrown out? Like, what dates are
not? I'm assuming everybody wants to be
there. So if we need to change it and we
can discuss it now as a group, that'd be
great.
>> I think it should probably been out to
all of us if there was any conflicts
that because I would like to be there
for that because there are some issues
that I would like to discuss and be
there but I that is a work night for me
and then
you have a conflict as well.
>> I probably the most difficult schedule.
I'll be out of town next week Monday
through Thursday evening. So I have the
most difficult schedule. So if I can't
be there, that's fine.
>> So
>> if the clerk can Let's just throw an
email out there for some other
suggestions on dates.
>> Mr. President,
>> yeah,
>> the special meeting will serve no
purpose if we don't have it prior to the
22nd. And uh right,
>> I'm available Monday night only
>> and I requested the meeting. If you
know, if everybody can't be there, I
don't know. We're going to find a date
where everybody can be there.
>> Yeah,
>> we can try.
>> We can try.
>> How about Thursday night? Are you back
>> for Thursday evening?
>> I'm actually getting back late that
night. So, I will only be back Thursday
night. So, that's okay.
>> But I think we just heard the mayor say
he he's only available on Monday.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Correct. Is that what you said?
>> That's correct. I
>> I can cancel a couple engagements, but
that's tough to do.
Okay.
Um,
I'll get with
President Porter. I We can
>> We'll figure something out as far as
even by chance. How long was it that you
knew we were needed to have this
meeting? I mean, is it just a moment
thing?
>> No. When we called it is when we knew we
needed to have it.
This is a request of uh discussion with
Councilman Als and others about
fireworks that happened. And if we are
going to put fireworks legislation in
place before the end of the year and
have three readings, we need to move on
it now. But it also allows for a
discussion prior to proposing
legislation. So that's the purpose of
the special meeting to have an open
discussion publicly so we can hear pros
and cons on uh fireworks legislation
and then if appropriate bring a first
reading at the next regular meeting. Um,
you may or may not know, but there was a
significant fireworks display on the
east side that was much beyond uh
residential recreational fireworks and
and well beyond what was permitted. And
u the residents were
put at risk, for lack of a better term.
I mean, we're talking about uh a
fireworks display of commercialrade
fireworks literally going over tops of
homes that are 25 30 feet away from that
display.
And
>> for 30 minutes.
>> Oh yes, for 30 minutes. U
>> do we have and I saw the invite and I
apologize. Is there do we have an
agenda? Is is that is was there
something else that
>> Yeah.
>> We also would like to discuss the South
Central Power legislation that's been
sitting on the table on and off for a
year and uh allow for a discussion of
they have a request to modify uh the
legislation in front of you that's on
the table to have a limit of 25 megawws
that would allow anything under that
threshold to be served by South Central
Power. We have a counter proposal of
five megawws,
but we want you to understand what those
are, how big they are. So, we're going
to have an opportunity at that evening
to discuss the size of each one of those
developments, what it might mean to this
legislation, and whether it's
appropriate for us to amend
the legislation that's on the table.
>> Okay.
>> Can I just add something?
>> Sure.
Uh when the state legalized fireworks in
2022,
I I'm not sure that they really thought
it through.
And that happens. And what they do is
they they they dump it on the city. And
what we have is a situation where you're
asking a police officer to evaluate
whether all of the
uh required regulations are being
followed to be allowed to set off
fireworks and they're not qualified to
do that.
Most of them can measure 150 ft. But
where that you get into a technical
difference is the difference between a
1.4G 4G, which is allowed, and a 1.3G,
which is considered professional grade
and not allowed.
Well, I'm not an expert either, but I'm
going to tell you that on Labor Day
weekend, what I saw was professional
grade. It I thought it was it sounded
like someone got a great deal on the
fireworks that they didn't set off at
the festival, like half price or
something. and just decided to set him
off on Labor Day. That's what it looked
like, sounded like, and I'm probably a
half mile away,
Tener.
>> So, this is probably in 2018 or 2019.
This had been handled back then before
they even were legal. They were being
shot off at Glasco Park. They were
professional grade. Remember that? You
were on counsel. I called you. You were
on on parks.
>> Sure. And you even told me on the phone,
oh, they should have because the cops
showed up, watched it, fullblown blown
fireworks just like they were doing at
at the fairgrounds that night. They went
on for two hours.
Cops showed up. He sat there for two
minutes and watched him and then drove
away. And because I told that to you
then, see this? So, this should have
been handled a long time ago.
>> I don't think it's the same.
>> It's not situation. This is Huffer
Drive. The houses are fine. It's like
seven years ago before it was legal is a
whole different
but I'm just saying these things should
have been taken care of.
>> Different situation.
>> No, it isn't.
>> Okay. Go ahead.
>> This is why we were wanting to have a
special meeting about it. I guess
>> public property they were prohibited
under the new law. Also, state law
prohibits Glasco Park or any public
property. Uh so that should have been
cut and dried. And you're right. I do
know the enforcement did not take place
that day.
>> No, it didn't. They they drove away and
everybody started clapping. That's why
I'm saying that I mean they should take
care of it when they see it. Period.
>> We We feel the same I feel the same way
about what just happened on Labor Day.
It could have been enforced and it
wasn't.
>> Go ahead.
>> Is there any permitting process or any
kind of
>> Wait, wait, wait.
>> That's okay. I'm willing to wait. I will
just say I wanted to add on to what
Councilman Als was uh pointing out is
not only are we asking our law
enforcement to make these decisions by
the time they are called out. It's in
the middle of a display. So, we're
asking to make these decisions in the
middle of a firework display, which they
can't measure out and they can't see
what the grade of those fireworks are.
So the whole purpose of this exercise is
for us as a city to decide what do we
want to allow, how do we want to allow
it, and maybe put forth some sort of
permitting so that we can have the
ability to
understand what the citizens are wanting
to do ahead of time so that we have the
time to look at what are the grade of
the fireworks, where are they going to
be located, and make certain all those
safety practices are set prior to
someone letting off fireworks.
Yes. Okay. So,
>> a similar question is with permitting.
Was the state legislation did have any
guidelines for permitting or any
recommendations or no
>> of kind of to find a happy medium
between
>> they have not. However, we have been
looking at maybe like the city of
Columbus, they've put in restrictions.
So, we've kind of been looking at that
on what their ordinance states. Um it
looks like they have maybe some
practices that we could adopt um or
something at least to look at to start
the conversation.
Okay.
>> Anything else? Right now we're just
going to I'm just going to have you read
it as that's when the special meeting
scheduled. And if something changes
between now and then if you want to if
it doesn't change then
email your
concerns or topics or give it to
President Porter or myself and we can
bring those up at the meeting and then
we'll go from there. Again, that's just
to prep for the idea of are we bringing
something?
>> There would be no legislation voted on
at that point.
>> Right. Exactly. We're just what are our
options meeting? Have we determined
where this will take place? Will it take
place here or at 1987 room?
>> Pardon?
>> The 1897 room.
>> Okay. All right.
>> And I'll have a full agenda.
>> So, we're good on that for now. We'll
move to the announcements of scheduled
meetings, including the special meeting.
>> Um, I have next regular sessions of
council September 22nd, 2025 at 6:30 in
in council chambers. October 6, 2025 at
6:30 p.m. um in council chambers.
>> Special scheduled meetings.
>> I have upcoming special meeting um
September 15, 2025 at 6:00 p.m. in city
hall 1897 conference room.
And then upcoming meeting committee
meetings for the next 30 days. Water
water pollution control service
committee September 15th at 7:30 a.m.
City Hall 1897 conference room. Public
works committee September 19th at 7:30
a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room. And
then finance committee September 22nd 6
p.m. council chambers.
>> All right. Thank you very much.
Yeah, you can do that.
Um, sorry, I'm gonna slide backwards
here. If we want to do the little
roundroin on any updates from everyone
and their committees, I'll start with
Mr. Sully.
>> The only update we have is with our
short-term rental, there's going to be a
public hearing uh to cover the changes
that were are being made.
>> Okay. is my understanding that we're
reworking some of that and it has to go
back to planning commission.
>> That's accurate. So, we're we're working
on that on the administration side and
we'll have something for uh for that
committee meeting.
>> Okay.
>> To consider
>> for October October's meeting, right?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Perfect. Mr. Bisjack of safety.
>> Uh nothing from the safety committee at
this time. Thank you, Mr. President.
>> Mr. Luck.
>> Nothing at this time.
>> Mr.
service committee met on Friday and I'm
happy to report that Bowers Park will be
included in the 2026 budget and will
also be whatever they can't get done
with the seating and back stop that will
be included in whatever financing
package they put together for Miller
Park. So, we're moving forward. Thank
you.
>> Right, Mr. Crates.
>> Uh just a reiteration of what Mr.
Bisjack mentioned that the South Central
Power legislation will be covered under
the special meeting.
>> Thank you, M. Tiner.
>> Um, our M um, um, public works will be
September the 19th, believe it was going
to be, I think, the 12th. And then
they're going to, I think Curt's going
to say what roads are going to be paid
for next year.
>> Great. I hate to skip you, but do you
want to give an update? Are you feeling
good? Well, since we talked about Miller
Park, I can do a shameless plug.
>> Sure. Uh
>> full of shameless plugs tonight.
>> Lancaster Rotary um is in the process of
raising funds for the new playground at
the new Miller Park. Um today it was
announced we've reached the $650,000
mark, which is exciting. The last 350 is
the hardest. Um, with that in mind, we
are having a fundraiser uh the 20th 4 to
7 downtown uh and uh the battle of the
bands. Five local bands will be
performing and tickets are available.
>> Very nice. As a Kowanas member, I feel
like we did our
>> you then you definitely need to buy a
ticket.
>> Way cheaper.
>> I do believe Rotary donated to the
Kuanas cause.
>> Okay. So, Rotary did donate to the
Quanas cause. That is true. I I wasn't
totally slam. I'm just saying
>> question. What what what day is that
going to be fun?
>> This Saturday.
>> It's Yes. The 20th.
>> A week from Saturday.
>> Yes.
>> Perfect.
>> Mr. Wing. Yes. Uh water water pollution
committee. Next meeting is uh next
Monday morning at 7:30. Uh most of the
legislation we discussed at our last
meeting is currently on the agenda and
being read by our wonderful council
clerk. And uh the only other thing I
want to give a heads up about is um due
to some uh in the last administration
federal uh lend copper rules uh we will
have to um amend some ordinances in
chapter 911 to comply with the new
federal rules. So that is currently
being drafted and will be coming uh to
us shortly.
>> Okay. Thank you. Mrs. who
>> um there are
turn it back on. Um economic development
next meeting is October 30th at 7:30. Um
and then Stephanie's gone, but I think
you can still contact her if you want to
go to the state of the county on
September 30th. Just reach out to her.
I'm going. So,
>> okay.
Thank you. Anybody on that end of the
table before we move on? No. All right.
Thank you. Uh reading of bills, please.
>> Um I have one for $14248
for publication of ordinances.
>> Make a motion to pay the bills.
>> Second.
>> Motion and second to pay the bills. All
in favor signify by saying I.
>> I.
>> Motion carries. No need for an executive
session that I'm aware of. So I will
take a motion that we adjourn.
>> Mr. President Prom I make a motion to
for the meeting to be adjourned.
>> Second
>> second.
>> Motion and a second to adjourn. All in
favor?
>> I.
>> We are adjourned. Please remember to
sign your legislation and
>> I think I signed
>> spay and ne to your pets. Have a good
evening.
[Music]